Juan comenzamos con nuestra cobertura
especial del mundial de atletismo verdad
sí Santiago avanza el segundo día de
estas justas Que transcurren en la costa
oeste de Estados Unidos la jornada
inaugural comenzó ayer de manera muy
destacada para América Latina con dos
medallas de oro por eso conectamos a
esta hora con Juan José sayago nuestro
enviado especial para este mundial Juan
ya habíamos destacado ayer ese oro de
Kimberly García histórico en la marcha
para Perú pero a esa fiesta se sumó
República Dominicana con el relevo
sí Juan Cómo estás Saludos estamos acá
en Eugene ya en esta segunda jornada de
hecho las personas están entrando al
estadio para disfrutar de esta de esta
jornada en la tarde ayer el relevo
dominicano tuvo varias connotaciones esa
Victoria esa medalla de oro y
convertirse en campeones mundiales del
4x400 tuvo que ver primero con el hecho
de que por primera vez dos mujeres para
la República Dominicana obtuvieron
medallas en campeonatos del mundo y
después era la despedida de Alison Félix
y el estadio este que están mis espaldas
terminó silenciado por esa medalla de
oro de República Dominicana con ellos
conversamos después de esa
extraordinaria Victoria y esto fue lo
que nos dijeron vamos a escucharnos y
cuando vi esa americana adelante dije el
futuro dominicano atendó paso de ese
campeón mundial de ese campeón mundial y
no hubiese y le pedí a dios y Dios me
respondió y me dio la oportunidad de ser
ese cierre espectaculares tenemos una
medalla
la primera como campeón mundial de
relevo mixto y vamos por la individual
Juan y que sacamos de lo que va de
jornada de sábado
en lo que va de jornada a Juan bueno la
quinta medalla de oro de manera
consecutiva para el polaco Power o el
falle tiró 8198 en el lanzamiento de
Martillo Y como te digo fue la quinta
medalla de oro consecutiva también la
medalla de oro para lentes de Etiopía en
los 10.000 metros 30 0994 lo que
representó una un nuevo récord mundial
en esta distancia para la etíope pero en
Latinoamérica se vio representado con
una figura de la cual se espera
muchísimo de ella por supuesto hablamos
de yulimar rojas quien apenas en su
primer salto logró colocar
1472 para meterse en su tercera final de
mundiales
abiertos de manera consecutiva vamos a
escuchar que dijo yulimar Después de
conseguir su pase a la final
ninguna preocupación Entonces no sé creo
que lo ha ido adquiriendo ya con la con
la experiencia con los años y sobre todo
con la confianza en mí misma
Sí ahí veíamos entonces lo que nos
dejaba yulimar rojas que como decía va a
ser la tercera final consecutiva para
tratar de convertirse también en la
primera triplista de toda la historia en
Conseguir tres medallas de oro en los
campeonatos mundiales de atletismo de
resto en noticias y no muy alentadoras
para Italia Aparentemente Jacob se
estaría perdiendo la semifinal Y por
supuesto la posibilidad de conseguir una
medalla de oro en los 100 metros planos
la prueba reina que se va a definir al
final de la jornada de esta campeonato
mundial de atletismo que ya está por su
segundo round esto ha sido una fiesta
extraordinaria para los habitantes de
Oregón Y quienes han visitado de todo el
mundo ya que las delegaciones han tenido
una representación importantísima
después de esa victoria de etíope por
ejemplo los pasillos de este escenario
eran eran una fiesta total